das ist unser aller schuld dass wir
solche situationen haben entstehen
lassen ja und da kann sich keiner
ausnehmen gibt ja auch politischen
wettbewerber im bundestag spd eher der
grüne die schon bei den mandaten im märz
völlig uneinheitlich gestimmt haben da
wäre es auch gut gewesen wenn alle zu
dem einsatz gestanden hätten jetzt endet
er und er endet mit diesen schrecklichen
bildern jetzt erleben wir auch in diesen
stunden marcus hotze sonderbeauftragter
des auswärtigen amts wir verhandeln
plötzlich mit taliban wir haben auch
gesagt okay die kriegen jetzt wieder ein
bisschen ein paar millionen am ende
finanzieren wir doch damit wieder terror
lassen wir müssen jetzt erstmal alles
tun dass die taliban die jetzt ja die
macht in afghanistan haben das nehmen
sie einfach so hin ja gut die
alternative ist ja die bundeswehr
einsatz noch einmal zu verlängern das
kann die bundeswehr nicht alleine die
amerikaner aber sie haben nicht mal
versucht sozusagen mit allianz zusammen
zwischen den us amerikaner wechselt ja
nicht mal versucht also sagen ist ein
lasst uns das machen mit den franzosen
mitarbeitern lernen und uns versucht das
ist aber eine der lehren die wir jetzt
auch zu politischen konsequenzen bringen
müssen wir können es einfach nicht
europa kann nicht alleine einen solchen
einsatz machen und deshalb habe ich
gesagt wir brauchen jetzt mechanismen
dazu muss man natürlich geld geben dazu
muss man den willen haben dazu muss man
streitkräfte haben die im zweifel auch
den flughafen von kabul sichern wieso
können eigentlich nur amerikaner einen
kleinen flughafen sichern warum sind wir
als europäer nicht die bundeswehr
alleine als europäer dazu nicht in der
lage und das muss nach dieser lehre
unser ziel sein auch international nicht
in der ganzen welt aber bei bestimmten
einsätzen als europäer handlungsfähig
werden und wenn ich noch ein satz sagen
darf wir haben schon mal so eine
situation gehabt das war in den 90er
jahren auf dem balkan da gab es massen
vergewaltigungen ethnische säuberungen
milosevic hat einen krieg gegen die
muslimische minderheit die boßler damals
geführt und danach haben die europäer
gesagt jetzt beginnen wir mit einer
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik weil erst die
amerikaner und dann haben alle wäre
gelabert oder ich will es passiert dann
hat so können sie hier auch wieder sagen
dass wir das brauchen es wieder auf
passieren lieber herr alzheimer ich war
damals im europäischen parlament an
diesen fragen beteiligt wir haben uns
viel vorgenommen man hat wenig geschafft
man hat etwas geschaffen angeschaut doch
es gibt schon erste könnten wir den
flughafen sich eben das können wir nicht
und das ist jetzt die aufgabe es jetzt
hinzukriegen
[Musik]